everybody welcome welcome welcome in to
another edition of Market takes listen I
know you could have been anywhere in the
world but you're here with me and I
appreciate that I am Dion rabone
reporter at the Wall Street Journal I
know we left you for a little bit too
long last Market takes was like last
Monday I've heard a couple y'all in my
email inbox talking about what's going
on Market takes we are back I wouldn't
have ever left you without letting you
know without saying goodbye so listen
today we are diving into the latest jobs
report the jobs report from August it's
the first day of September and already
we got the jobs report we don't even
have to wait it's a beautiful thing we
saw addition of jobs this month a big
increase 187 000 which actually was the
same as what we added last month but
things have gotten a little bit sticky
I'm going to talk about that in just a
second so listen here's what we're going
to talk about on today's market takes
we're going to talk about what the
report said how that compared with
expectations and also get into a trend
that I've noticed on the jobs report
that I don't think I I don't hear
anybody else talking about it's been
going on all year we're going to get
into that we're going to talk about some
standout numbers in the report there
were a lot of things that really kind of
snuck below just the headline numbers in
terms of the inflation or the
unemployment rate and the number of jobs
added we are going to talk about those
of course we're going to get into the
market reaction how stocks bonds
currencies uh Commodities all those
things responded to this report and of
course we're going to talk about the
current market Focus how investors are
viewing this jobs report and how this
sets us up for what's coming next in
terms of other data and of course we're
going to look ahead to the fed's
September meeting that meeting is coming
in less than three weeks so we're going
to get you ready for that in just a
minute here and of course we're going to
talk about what's next because we are
always looking forward here on Market
takes even though it is backward looking
data so without further Ado let's get
into it the U.S economy added a hundred
eighty seven thousands 187 uh for the
month let's throw a chart up here on
your screen just so you can see what
we're talking about in terms of the
number of jobs we've seen so there's a
couple things that stick out here number
one you are seeing consistently lower
highs right you see that number in
February 2022 that was up near a million
and we have seen the highs as as those
jobs have jumped up in successive months
they haven't been as high you're also
seeing lower lows I think really
interesting the data we got today again
added 187 000 jobs in August that was
more than expected uh the expectations
were for 170 000 jobs to be added the
unemployment rate to be 3.5 percent the
rate was actually 3.8 percent but let's
stick to these job ads numbers now what
you're seeing is July was revised down
to 157 000. the original report said 187
000 well it got revised down to 157 000
and June was actually revised lower by a
hundred thousand jobs so you're saying
now that June number at 105 000 that's
the lowest the weakest month of job gain
since December 2020. the other thing
that you notice here now that we've had
those revisions right all those months
have been revised lower June revised
lower July revised lower and then we got
this report for August
you see the number of jobs starting to
pick up again now one thing I want to
talk about and really what this chart
illustrates is just a a trend that I've
been seeing and I went to the BLS the
Bureau of Labor Statistics website
because I was like am I am I crazy or am
I seeing what I think I'm saying I'm
seeing what I think I'm seeing we have
consistently had lower revisions every
single month it seems like the job
numbers comes out High when we get that
first report it's you know something
High 187 000 like we got this month or
187 like we got last month or 185 000
like we got in June and then when the
revisions come out it's lower and the
next month comes out and that previous
month is revised lower we have seen that
every single month this year I'm on the
BLS website right now July revised lower
by 30 000 June revised lower by 104 000.
every single month this year has been
revised lower so every month the uh the
BLS comes down they said okay this many
jobs were added they send out a bunch of
surveys to jobs to employers to people
they make calls they say Hey you know
how many people do you have work in
there give us your head count numbers
probably 50 to 60 percent of those
people get back to them by their
deadline so they can get the report out
by the time that it's expected which is
today for August and usually it's that
first it's the first Friday of the month
unless it's something crazy happens then
they push it back to the second Friday
but usually by that first Friday the
month they got out the report out so
they have to have the responses back by
about the second week in the preceding
month now more of those come in later on
and they follow up and they come back to
people and they say hey are you sure
about this what's what's really
happening and what we've seen every
single month this year is previous
months have been revised lower so
overall June has now been revised lower
by 104 000. May was revised lower by 58
000 April revised lower by 36 000. uh
march by 19 000 February by 63 000
January by 45 000. so every single month
this year now through July has been
revised lowered meaning that number that
we first got that when the market
reacted when things happened that's been
wrong and it's been overestimated every
single time now that that's a little
strange usually you have some higher
Vision some lower generally comes in
around the same you see the same Trend
but
I thought it was a little strange that
we've seen every single month revise
lower I went back and I checked the
numbers we have never and I went all the
way back to 1980 I couldn't keep going
because these reports are a little bit
cumbersome but going all the way back to
1980. that's 43 years ago there has not
been one single year when we've had net
negative revisions for the year and we
have had negative numbers every single
month this year the one revision that
was positive was March it was revised
Higher by 52 000 but still march overall
was revised lower by 19 000 because the
previous month before March had been
revised lower by so much or the previous
revision had been lowered by so much
here's why that matters when investors
are making their plans when they're
buying stock when they're saying okay
the U.S economy is doing this here's the
trend here's what's going on they say
okay well what we've seen is this and so
we're seeing a moderation we're seeing a
much greater moderation of job gains
than what we expected and then what was
initially reported so when we when
investors are saying okay jobs went up
by 187 000 in July well now it actually
turns out it was only 150 000 and what
you're seeing is that increase now so we
had 105 000 in June 157 000 in July 187
000 in August and now you're starting to
see new trends emerge because of those
lower revisions those lower revisions
also have the tendency to not only kind
of change the trend but we're seeing now
consistently lower job growth than what
we had expected now that's good news for
the FED but it's also a bit bad news
because the economy is maybe not as
strong not as healthy as what we had
been expecting and it seems like
consistently month after month we see
that the economy was less healthy that
jobs were less robust that they were
less employment gains added than we
found out and it doesn't just seem that
way that's what it is so when the BLS
goes back and they say hey here's what's
really happening they're consistently
finding that there were lower jobs
growth less or fewer jobs added lower
jobs growth overall real quick let's
talk about the unemployment rate that
Rose to 3.8 percent also the number of
unemployed people increased by 514 000
so 514 000 more people uh that's 6.4
million unemployed people we've also
seen an average gain over the last 12
months of 271 000 last year at this time
it was 483
000 uh average gains average monthly job
gains so we have about halved what we
were doing not quite have don't don't at
me math nerds but down to 271 000 from
483 000 added up each month a year ago
that's a significant decline we have
seen a significant Decline and like I
said it's really come from those
revisions so we've been moving
consistently lower in terms of number of
jobs added but we're not finding out
just how much lower until one month two
months three months later so again we're
finding out about June and how weak that
month was the weakest month of job
gained since December 2020 but we're
just finding that out in September
that's an interesting theme and
something that I'm going to call up my
folks at the BLS and ask them about
what's going on why is the job data been
consistently wrong All in One Direction
that's unusual another big takeaway from
this report though that I want to make
sure and point out is we are seeing the
labor market slow down but maybe the BLS
needs to slow down in its reporting also
I think what really stands out though
again is that increase in unemployed
people we are also seeing an increase in
labor force participation labor force
participation gonna talk about that in
just a minute so let's talk really
quickly about the fed and what they want
to see and the number of jobs added
versus the number of people looking for
a job want to put a chart up here on
your screen so you can see just what
we're talking about see kind of an
illustration of that Trend this is what
Fed chair Jerome Powell is talking about
when he's talking about the the number
of job openings versus unemployed people
job openings have been consistently
coming down we see that in the jolts
report the job opening and labor
turnover survey you are seeing now a
very solid consistently downward number
that's that red line right there on your
screen you see it moving down with a
Vengeance it's really moving clearly in
that downward stance what you're also
seeing now is a pickup of unemployed
people that we had not seen for a while
that's largely been because a lot of
folks have just not been in the labor
force but now you see an increase and
you saw that late and so the
unemployment rate rise 3.8 percent and
now the number of unemployed people is
is rising if you look back the past 20
years we had really never seen this
theme before of more job openings this
is more people trying to hire folks than
there were unemployed folks to hire that
had never really happened going all the
way back to the history of this data and
now we're seeing consistently over a
longer term period the FED has really
focused on that and said that's a big
problem for the economy it's keeping
inflation high it's going to keep
inflation from coming back down and
that's something we need to deal with
um this now shows that that problem is
being dealt with finally after a long
time after the FED raised rates at the
fastest Pace in at least 40 years um
we're seeing now those things start to
come into harmony but as the economy
slows down maybe that's not such a good
thing so listen this chart just
illustrating the theme that we're seeing
and the trend that we're seeing in terms
of job growth and in terms of the number
of people looking to hire folks the
labor force the labor market coming back
into sync as the FED might put it but
that's not good news for you and me
that's not the good news for job Seekers
that's not good news for you know your
your cousin who's sitting on the couch
unemployed trying to find a job uh you
know the the job gains the opportunities
aren't really going to be there and it's
looking like things are coming in a
negative Direction in terms of Labor
Market but again the market really seems
to like it we'll talk about that in just
a second fewer hires and separations in
the previous month uh the market loved
the jolts report when it came out
because like I said this is exactly what
the FED wants and it's supporting the
negative the supporting the narrative
excuse me the jobs growth is slowing
that the the labor market can get back
into sync whether or not that's a good
good thing for average working folks
it's not but it's what the Federal
Reserve wants and that means that maybe
they don't have to raise rates as much
they don't have to rein in and slow down
the economy quite as much that is a good
thing one big surprise number I talked a
little bit about the labor force
participation rate that Rose by 0.2
percentage points to 62.8 percent that
labor force participation rate has been
stubborn you want to see that rise
because you want to see more folks
coming into the market those folks have
really just been off on what they call
the silence folks who are saying you
know they don't have a job but they're
not looking for a job they're doing
something else and they're not coming
out saying I'm trying to find a job
actively and so the Bureau of Labor
Statistics just categorizes those people
as out of the labor force there are only
three categories of people in this world
there are employed people unemployed
people and those people who are out of
the labor force and if you're out of the
labor force you're just kind of not
thought of now we've got about 37
percent of people a little over 30
percent of people in the US that's
retired people that's people who are
under the working age that's people who
are disabled it's all those folks but
it's also just people who aren't looking
for a job for whatever reason you know
maybe they've got a situation living
with mom living with a relative
something like that where they don't
need a job but all those people are not
working right now and that number is
starting to pick up and that's what the
FED wants to see because as those people
come back in they can fill those jobs
out and then you start to see maybe less
pressure on the on the side of on the
side of employers to maybe pay more
because these people haven't had a job
at all so anything is better than
nothing and so they're not really
pushing those wage gains up higher which
isn't pushing up inflation which means
inflation can come back down those wage
gains can get kind of back into balance
at least that that's how the Federal
Reserve thinks of it it's very unusual
though I will say it's very unusual to
see an increase in labor force
participation and also an increased
unemployment basically what that means
is someone who hasn't had a job for a
long time or hasn't been actively
looking for work for a long time is
coming in and saying well I don't have a
new job but I'm unemployed now I'm
officially unemployed I'm just telling
you this because you know you called me
the BLS calls folks and I say hey are
you unemployed are you looking for a job
and now what we're seeing is an influx
of people who are saying they're looking
for work but don't have work usually
when the labor force participation rate
goes up it's because people have found a
new job they say oh yeah I got a new job
what they're seeing now is it's picking
up just because people are saying yeah
no I'm looking for a job now I don't
have one but I'm looking very unusual
doesn't really happen and definitely
something to keep your eye on listen
let's talk about markets let's take a
look at what's going on in the markets
want to throw a chart up here on your
screen and show you what's happening
right now overall in markets you're
seeing the stock market really rise the
Dow has been up strong the NASDAQ
actually got negative for a little while
and is now back up positive we're seeing
the S P 500 the overall market index up
about half a percent really interesting
response that we got from bonds when I
throw that up here on your screen as
well look at that huge jump in the
30-year Bond it's only up six basis
points but that big move this happened
right after the job support came out you
saw the same thing in the 10-year kind
of went down negative initially but then
boom jump right back up but you don't
see that same kind of response from
these shorter dated notes look at the
seven year you see the same response but
not by as much and as you go down the
yield curve is in as you go down to the
shorter data maturities you're seeing
lower and lower to the point that really
it was still negative for the three year
for the two year and and across the
board on these long on the shorter dated
yields so that I think was really
interesting the response that we got
there from the bond market currencies
you saw the Euro turn negative that
means the dollar strengthened basically
the dollar strengthened across the board
board this is showing us signs that
folks expect inflation and growth to
continue to pick back up and that's I
think just on the headline number
increased uh jobs more jobs added than
expected 187 000 versus 170 000 and like
I said the market reaction right now
just illustrating the overall theme that
we see in markets which is just that you
know growth is going to continue
inflation may be higher for longer and
the FED may have to do a little bit more
work but there's not a lot of conviction
you don't see folks you don't see the
bond market selling off you don't see
stocks selling off in fact stocks are
positive in the green so this selling
this suggesting that you know the the
economy could be doing a little bit
better but as you said when we dive into
those numbers really digging into the
report it's a little bit more of a
nuanced complicated picture I think
that's why the market doesn't have a lot
of conviction one way or another listen
let's talk about the current focus on
the job support how the market is
thinking of it investors want this soft
Landing Summer that we've had to
continue we have seen though some
deterioration and business the sentiment
in consumer sentiment glass consumer
confidence report we got from the
conference board was
ugly in terms of what people think about
their current situation and the future
not good but it is still all about
inflation which is cooling from the
highs but we are seeing inflation be a
little bit stubborn let's put another
chart up here on your screen really
quick so I can just show you what I'm
talking about when it comes to inflation
as you see there on your screen
inflation consistently coming down now I
usually show you the CPI Consumer Price
Index I'm showing you the pce personal
consumption expenditures which is the
fed's favorite gauge this is what the
FED says they watch right I'm showing
you this for a reason now the CPI we saw
it was a little bit higher went up over
the nine percent and usually see those
big pickups over nine percent uh when we
look at the CPI back in 2022 and then
coming down we see the same theme here
from the pce but it's lower and as we
get towards these readings it's been
consistently lower but now it's matching
up almost exactly with CPI the past two
numbers have been almost exactly the
same on CPI and PC now why does that
matter CPI and pce are different indexes
they measure things differently and the
reason the FED prefers the PC number one
it updates its basket more often meaning
what people buy changes people are
buying more of one thing less of another
thing remember during the pandemic folks
were buying a lot of stuff in terms of
we're stocking up for what's going to be
in our house we're doing cooking at home
all those things we're doing a little
bit less of that now we're going out to
restaurants and bars things like that so
those baskets change the PC updates that
more often than CPI right you also see
things like Medical Care gets a higher
wages housing plays a much larger role
in CPI than in PC and that's a big part
of why pce is important right now
because the pce index adjusts for things
like when folks are buying steak and
then all of a sudden wow man steak is
getting too expensive because of
inflation I'm going to switch to
Hamburger well the CPI doesn't account
for differences in steak for hamburger
the pce does it also has a much bigger
appetite for changes in things that
people buy rather than just what they
spend on housing and transportation it's
a lot more about how businesses are
responding and changing things so pce
being right up next to CPI that's
interesting and also takes away the
opportunity for the FED to when they are
leaning towards making a hike pointing
to CPI but when they're leaning towards
stopping rate hikes and maybe turning
around pointing to PC because it's lower
now those two gauges are basically
exactly the same and you're seeing a
pickup in inflation in both CPI and pce
so that pickup means inflation is being
stubborn it's not consistently moving
back down toward the fed's two percent
Target and this chart really just
illustrates that stubbornness right the
fact that inflation isn't just going
down in one consistent line it's not
linearly moving down it's picking back
up I want to read you a real quick quote
from fed share Jerome Powell he talked
about the the labor market he said quote
evidence of the tightness in the labor
market is no longer easing could also
call for monetary policy response
basically what that means is if we don't
see number of job gains going down we
don't see those job openings going down
if we don't see unemployment picking up
we may have to raise rates some more
this report really suggests that the FED
is in a good place that the market is
doing what they want it to do again not
so great for you and I not so great for
job Seekers out there but good for the
FED is and they don't have to raise
rates likely the market is saying
they're looking out and they're saying a
93 chance the FED doesn't raise rates in
September and about a 70 chance there
are no more rate hikes this year
um in terms of looking forward to the
Fed so really quickly Let's Talk About
That September fed meeting coming up the
19th and 20th of course we will be right
here on Market takes we hope you'll join
us we break that meeting down in
September the 20th at 4 pm but the jolts
report really reduced and the market saw
that and they said okay fed's not hiking
in September we're pretty sure this
report today really locked that in the
jolts report kind of increased the uh
the likelihood there were going to be no
more rate hikes uh to about 80 percent
now with this report it's over 90 93
chances of when we look at the FED
fund's Futures Market there's going to
be no rate hike this month and really
out through the end of the year odds
that there's going to be another rate
hike have been reduced 70 chance
investors see that there are no more
rate hikes through the end of the year
uh the big question though is this going
to be about fed summary of economic
projections do they predict they're
going to raise rates and again or do
they say you know what we raised rates
once a couple months ago we're done with
all that we think the economy is cooling
down doing exactly what we needed to do
this jobs report today suggests that
they could do that the question is will
they what is the fed's bias what are
they thinking how are they moving we're
going to find out on the 19th and 20th
of of this month and we'll find out on
the 20th when Fed chair Jerome Powell
does his press conference and we're
breaking it down here on Market takes
listen the fed's beige book is out on
Wednesday detailing the economy we are
going to dive into that talk about small
business talk about how the economy is
doing talk about Job games talk about
Job losses we're going to get an
in-depth look at the economy on
Wednesday 4 P.M right here on Market
takes we hope you'll be there or be a
don't do it don't be a square anyway I'm
Dion Robert Bowen for the Wall Street
Journal this has been Market takes we
hope you will join us next time we do it
again